There's a version of your life that only
exists right now. In 6 months, you won't
be able to see it anymore. Not because
you'll forget, because the door closes.
You clicked on this for a reason.
Something ended recently or it's ending.
That weird nameless place where you're
not who you were, but you're not who
you're becoming either. You wake up and
for a split second everything's normal.
Then you remember the job ended, the
relationship ended, someone left. And
the strange part, sometimes it's not
sadness, it's just nothing. You're not
broken. You're not behind. You're in
what researchers call the neutral zone.
This disorientation isn't a sign
something's wrong with you. It's a sign
something is working exactly as it
should. And there are things visible
from where you're standing that become
invisible once you move. The Greeks had
a word for where you are right now. They
called it liinal. And what most people
don't realize, the confusion isn't the
obstacle. The confusion is the carder.